[Music]
I've talked to a bunch of people I've
had I don't know D no T no Sun and
dodging you from yes of course okay so
I've had I've had him on and I get a lot
of mail from people in Sweden
particularly but Denmark also you're
talking about the rise of Islamism and
talking about how this is happening in
the in the mosques and it's happening in
the public square now and we know that
there's a rape epidemic and a whole
series of problems so if the best
defense is to let these people say what
they want but isn't the problem that
we're still seeing these bad ideas rise
well because it is the problem of the
Islamism worse now than it was say five
years ago in Denmark it is so then what
about an inherent conflict man with with
the idea of sort of full free speech
no I yeah I I think you have to go
further back to identify the root causes
we had an understanding I mean I I
taught immigrants the Danish language
2530 years ago in Denmark and my wife is
an immigrant herself by the way from the
former Soviet Union and we had this
understanding if people arrived and they
just stay long enough in our country
they will become like us without you
know telling them what the rules of the
game are what our values are and so on
and so forth and we today we understand
that this doesn't happen in a by itself
even if you learn the language it
doesn't mean that that you start to
support the values and the foundation of
society so we have been we have been too
weak on communicating the foundation of
our society and and why why free speech
matters to us and and why you have to
have to accept that your religion may be
object of satire and criticism and and
and so on and so forth that that that
homosexuality is not a criminal offence
that equality between the sexes is
crucial I mean it's some of the most in
one of the most important things we
achieved in the second half of the 20th
century we're not we're not willing to
give that up and we have been very bad
at communicating these ideas and it all
exploded during the cartoon crisis yeah
and I think that's why we still talk
about those cartoons because that
conflict may be very clear this clash of
values so so so no I don't think that
that there is an inherent conflict I
mean we had anti-democratic movements
and forces also during the Cold War we
had we had a legal Communist Party in
Denmark that wanted to overthrow the
government they sat in Parliament they
had their own newspapers they had their
own unions they had their own festivals
they had their own schools but we did
not criminalize them we confronted them
and had this debate in in in public and
it turned out in the end that that
reason and the values of Liberty
prevailed yeah so this is really
sunlight is the best disinfectant
argument yes eventually these things
will crumble because they don't lead us
to actual human liberty and the things
that people want really yeah and if we
want to get more Muslims on our side we
have to be consistent and and make clear
to them that that if there are you know
individuals dissenters within Muslim
communities they have an opportunity to
to leave their religion and we have an
obligation to to to protect them yeah I
suspect I know the answer to this but
when I've had certain people including
ion and Maajid Nawaz and other Muslim
reformers like Faisal Saitama thar and
here is me and Sarah Hader and many of
these people on the show there's been a
theme which is that the left abandoned
them they started talking about these
ideas not being bigoted in that they are
Brown themselves yeah and that their
families often are still practicing
Muslims in the case of budget he still
is Muslim some of them are X Muslims but
that they felt abandoned by the side
that they wanted as their a liar that
should have been their natural ally I
suspect you got plenty of that yes
absolutely
I think that's true because if you look
at the Enlightenment and and the West
the criticism our religion came from the
left but the left abandoned its
insistence on criticizing religion when
when when Islam arrived and become
became a hot issue and I think that's
the middle to to the the core values of
of the left
I mean religion is power and it's a way
to to establish social control whether
it is you know by Christianity by Islam
by other other kinds of religion and and
in Denmark I mean the Socialist Party in
Denmark for 50 years they were in favor
of getting rid of the blasphemy law
mm-hmm today they defend the blasphemy
law because they now believe it's it's
important to have it to protect Muslims
and I think that's crazy our people
right now being prosecuted under the
blasphemy law not one no it's it's it's
a sleeping law I would say but but but
we we see that hate speech law we also
have a law against racism and we see
that the people are in fact being
prosecuted for racism for saying things
that actually is blasphemy for instance
comparing Islam with Nazism but it's
criticism of ideas not of individuals
so so there also is a slippery slope in
that direction so what do you make of
the far-right parties that seem to be
growing throughout Europe I'm not sure
is there a far-right party that's now
gaining momentum in Denmark I don't know
I mean depends on who on how to define
it I don't like the phrase fun right
exactly because our whole thing is so
crossed up now that I think was to be
far right is thought now is more Center
because they're the only ones talking
about certain issues and that then
brings in a lot of centrist people who
otherwise wouldn't vote for the right we
have to what I chew parses of this kind
one an old party that in fact is is the
second biggest party in Denmark the
Danish People's Party which I would say
is the second social democratic party
opposed to immigration and then we have
a rather new policy that is more
conservative for small government but
also anti-immigration but I would not
call them far-right I mean they are not
outside they don't want to to undermine
the political order you know through
violence like you for instance in
increase you have Golden Dawn right
which is more fascist movement and they
have nothing in common with we go and
don't even not was a marine lepen in in
in France yeah do you think that this is
the route that Europe is gonna go it
seems like it's just going to be the
reaction to what has happened Merkel
open the doors to 1.1 million people or
so and even if 95% of them integrate
perfectly it doesn't take a lot of
people well first of all that point
one's a lot of people but it doesn't
take a lot of people to so a lot of
chaos yeah a couple of points I think I
think polarization
will intensify this year we will have an
election in Netherlands where a populist
party get will ders probably will you
will not you will not get to run the
government but he may become the biggest
party what do you think someone like her
do you because I know he's sort of a lot
of people that I think I trust basically
say he really straddles the line I had
the babe with him absolutely and I we
disagree on the two most fundamental
building blocks of democracy equality
and freedom equality before the law and
the rights of freedom of expression
freedom of religion he is in favor if he
gets the power to to abandon the rights
of freedom of religion for Muslims
building mosques having faith-based
schools and so on and so forth and also
the freedom of speech he wants to pay in
the Koran so he's not willing to provide
the same fundamental freedoms to Muslims
as to Christians atheists and other
individuals so so we disagree on the
building blocks and the funny thing is
that if he gets into power he will use
exactly the same hate speech law against
Muslims that the current government has
used against him right for demonizing
Muslims which is he's been convicted
he's been convicted which i think is
crazy so he he can still run though you
know him it's a huge victory because he
will use that as a card in the election
campaign it's it's the best outcome he
could only dream of in fact so we will
we will see more polarization and I and
I think you know the underlying merits
him here is that that after the second
world war because of Nazism and fascism
Europe has has has has in a way
celebrated diversity which is great in
many ways I mean I also like diversity
but but at the same time Europe has not
been willing to face its own history
and the fact of the matter is that
Europe has been very bad at managing
diversity throughout its own history
after the first world war you had four
empires falling apart and you saw the
creation of a lot of homogeneous
nation-states in order to build a safe
as sustainable peace after the Second
World War
you switched populations in Europe in
order to reinforce homogeneous
nation-states
so so Europe in fact has tried to build
homogeneous nation-states in order to
avoid too much diversity within borders
of a state and and after the Second
World War you had only four states in
Europe that were multinational in their
construction the Soviet Union Yugoslavia
Czechoslovakia and Belgium today three
of those dates are gone yeah so so I I
think Europe has to be more honest about
our difficulties managing diversity it
doesn't mean that we shouldn't we
shouldn't we shouldn't try to manage
diversity we shouldn't try to take
people in and and look at the positive
things but we should be honest about how
painful and difficult it is and we
haven't so so so when when and I am
miracle welcomes a million refugees and
just and you know be a chef and us we
can do this it turns out that in real
life things
are not that easy and and it means that
a lot of frustration a lot of anger so
so so I believe that that Europe in the
coming years they will will face motive
more confrontation more polarization we
will see more terrorist attacks and we
will see the reaction among those
populist parties for taking harsher
measures against Muslims and if you take
the reasoned travel ban that was issued
by Donald Trump it's being welcomed by
these passes in in Europe and and they
will push for the same thing if they get
into government yeah that's actually
exactly what I was gonna ask you next do
you think that the average person that
maybe is living in France right now
where they have this major integration
problem with the poor a certain
percentage of their population do you
think they're looking at Trump now I'm
going wow you actually did it
you did what absolutely have done
absolutely and thus will then probably
vote yes Japan yes and I and I think the
mainstream parts is bear responsibility
because they were not willing to face up
to that problem even though voters for
many years have complained yeah
people just tell you you are stupid you
are backwards
why can't you manage this again
diversity is painful that's not easy so
so so now people welcome more radical
forces to take care of that problem so
basically if you won't deal with
something honestly someone's gonna come
in easy answer so if you were just the
average citizen in in France and let's
say France just completely closed their
borders altogether there's still an
integration problem there what's the
best way for for Denmark if you want to
answer it in that framework - what would
be the answer for the countries - to get
these people to be more integrated
that's whatever I think the average
Frenchman obviously wants that and I
think that's ultimately what these
people want - if they could get a fuller
picture
perhaps of what Western civilization
really well I was I would start to
reform the welfare state and I will cut
benefits so that people would be forced
to provide for themselves at an earlier
stage too many people in Europe from the
Middle East they never enter the labor
market and and work is a very effective
mechanism of integration and and getting
the sense of belonging to many of these
people they don't have they don't have
they don't have a sense of belonging to
society they are outside they they never
talk to a native citizens only at the
social welfare office
they don't have colleagues they leave
and they they live in these family
communities so so so cutting down the
welfare state because the welfare state
is or is also build on the principle of
similarity the people share the same
values that they have they more or less
share the same understanding of
obligation and rights but but we are
getting more and more diverse and people
have different understandings of what it
means to be a citizen of what a good
life is so so so we cannot we cannot fit
all these people into a more homogeneous
understanding of the welfare welfare
state that used to be the case so so so
so forcing people to work at an earlier
stage and getting rid of hate speech
loans because Muslims in fact are also
being prosecuted now for anti-semitic
speech in in in many Holocaust deniers
among Muslims in
in your radical Imams so so they don't
feel that we have a double standard you
know we go after them but we don't go
after people who are criticizing Islam
for instance friends that's a huge
problem where you don't have less
similar and Charlie Abdul can really
mark Islam but they do have laws
criminalizing denial of the Holocaust
which means that there are Muslims who
are being prosecuted for anti-semitism
while people critical of Islam are not
being prosecuted for marking Islam I
believe there it there is a difference
but I think it's a moral one right and
it shouldn't be a legal one
[Music]
you